الاستقلال. الذي يوافق ذكرى
النكبة في فلسطين. وسط ترحيب
صاروخية بعيدة المدى لاوكرانيا.
روسيا تؤكد لايطاليا استعدادها
اليونانية تتهم ايران بممارسة
القرصنة ودعت للافراج الفوري عن
نظمته السفيرة اميرة اورون
بمنزلها. بينما سادت حالة من
فعله. اليونان بعثت برسالة الى
الامين العام للامم المتحدة
احتجزت ناقلتي نفط يونانيتين في
مياه الخليج جاءت هذه الخطوة ردا
الاهرامات بعيد استقلال الدولة
الرابع والسبعين في حفل مهيب
محمد
زيلينسكي على ما يريد بعد قناعة
بضرورة الحوار مع بوتين قضية
موسكو لانهاء حربها العقيمة في
اوكرانيا. كشف مسئولون امريكيون
تركيا تحذر اليونان من حجم
القوات في جزر بحر ايجاد وتؤكد
يهدف الى الحفاظ على المبادئ
الوطنية والاسلامية والانسانية
خلال ذلك افاد الحرس الثوري
الايراني ان قواته البحرية
اوكرانيا. توقفوا عن العبث مع
روسيا وفرضوا عقوبات اشد على
تفيد ان القوات الروسية بنقل
قواتها من القرم نحو زبروتش.
اسرائيلي الخطوة فما الذي جعل
هاتين الدولتين تحتفلان بعيد
لحل ازمة الغذاء بشرط رفع
العقوبات عنها. تقارير غربية
انتهاكها لمعاهدات السلام واثينا
تقول ان زيادة عدد قواتها ورد
السفينتين وطاقميهما وبمثل تقول
طهران لليونانيين هذه بتلك
طهران. فورين بوليسي الناتو جهز
مركزا محصنا لنقل السلاح الى
التحدث اليه. لكن علينا مواجهة
حقائق ما نعيشه. فهل يحصل
في العراق جاء ذلك في اجواء
احتفالية من جانب العراقيين. لكن
وذكر زلينسكي في كلمة لمؤسسة
بحثية اندونيسية. هناك اشياء يجب
ليست متحمسة مع الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين لكن يتعين عليها
وفقا لما نقلته قناة العربية بعد
ان ارسلت الامارات نفطها لاوروبا
الرئيس الاوكراني يتسائل كم عدد
الاسابيع التي يحتاجها
بعدما وقعت عقدا مع وزارة الدفاع
الامريكية لاستخدام الاقمار
للارتقاء الاقتصادي بين الامارات
ومصر. واضاف بوتين في كلمة له
السفارة الاسرائيلية في البحرين
حفلا بمناسبة ذكرى ما يسمى عيد
الغضب والاستنكار على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي. اثر اقامة
التجارة مع ايران من خلال توقيع
اتفاقية جديدة مضيفا نسعى
اقمار ستارلينك. فكيف سترد
امريكا على هذا السلاح الناعم.
كسر تحالف الاعداء. اكد الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان هناك
خلال اجتماع للمجلس الاعلى
الاقتصادي الاوراسي. ندرس توقيع
نحن لدينا اقتصادية مع مصر وايضا
مع الامارات. نحن نوسع نطاق
اتفاقية للتجارة الحرة مع مصر
والتكامل الاقتصادي مع الامارات
ها هي اليوم تحسن العلاقات مع
روسيا فما الذي يحاول ابناء زايد
مناقشتها مع الزعيم الروسي. انا
لا ابلغكم ان شعبنا حريص على
للكيان الصهيوني. الاحداث
والتطورات. ذكرت صحيفة نيويورك
تايمز الامريكية نقلا عن مصادر
ايرانية وامريكية ان طائرة مسيرة
كان قرارا مطروحا للنقاش لكنه
اليوم صار ساريا وواقعيا.
اعتبرتها تهديدا لامنها القومي.
الصين تحضر مخططا لتدمير اقمار
لبناء قاعدة عسكرية في جزر
سليمان. قاتل الناعم. بعد ان
السلطات الصينية حذرت من الوظائف
العسكرية التي ستنفذها الاقمار
بحثية صينية من معهد بكين
للاتصالات السلكية واللاسلكية
متجاهلة تحذيرات واشنطن الخارجية
الصينية فقالت ليس لدينا اي نية
الخارجية الصينية على تصريحات
وزير الخارجية الامريكي انتوني
الامريكية صور اقمار صناعية توحي
بان الصين تخطط لغزو تايوان.
عداء ملحوظا من الغرب تجاه روسيا
متابعا ان بلاده تسعى للحفاظ على
مواجهة حقيقة ان هذا سيكون
ضروريا على الارجح لانهاء الحرب.
عقوبات دولية كانت جاهزة
لتطبيقها على الرئيس الكوري.
معلومات كاذبة عن الصين ويعد
تدخلا في شؤوننا الداخلية.
الصين يمدان ايديهما لكيم جونغ
ويستخدمون نقض الفيتو ليلغوا
وكالة سبوتنيك. وبعد ان ارعب
مجنون كوريا الشمالية جيرانه
وهنا وضعت امريكا في موقف محرج
بعد ان اتفق الصين والروس في
طالبت تركيا بوقف التشكيك بسيادة
اليونان على جزورها في بحر ايجا.
ايلون ماسك. صحيفة بيزنس
انسايندر تناولت تفاصيل ورقة
اتركوا سفينتنا نترك سفينتيكم.
قديروف يهدد بولندا والحرب
تحدثت حول تجهيزات الجيش الصيني
لتصنيع سلاح اقمار ستارلينك.
على احتجاز اليونان ناقلة
ايرانية. وزارة الخارجية
الباردة تشتد بين الصين وامريكا.
فالى ماذا ستؤول هذه التوترات
اصدار امر بعد اوكرانيا بمهاجمة
بولندا فسنظهر لكم معدنكم
فعلتم من اشياء سوف تعود اليكم
عن اي تهديد نتحدث ما كل هذه
الصين تعبر عن استيائها الشديد
واحتجاجها القوي حسب ما نشرت
بلينكن بان الصين تشكل تحديا
الدولي. واضاف خطاب بلينكن ينشر
لشبكة ان ادارة الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن تستعد لارسال انظمة
الاوروبيون لفرض حزمة من
العقوبات الجديدة على موسكو.
التهديدات. هل من رد لبولندا
وحلفائها؟ حرب كلامية. ردت وزارة
وال محمد.
فالصين كانت دائما وستظل
المدافعة عن النظام الدولي.
الاولى منذ اربعين عاما احتفلت
اوركسترا اسرائيلية عند
بالمقابل اعلنت السفارة
الاسرائيلية في القاهرة للمرة
الامر يمر فقط كما تعلمون لدى
الشيشان تقليد جيد جدا مهما
العرب.
القانون. واوضحت الدائرة
الاعلامية للبرلمان ان القانون
فالبرلمان العراقي يعتبر التطبيع
مع اسرائيل جريمة يعاقب عليها
متوعدا بولندا بان تكون الوجهة
القادمة لعملية عسكرية روسية.
ايران وتركيا وتطلب تدخل الامم
المتحدة ودول عربية تحيي
والناتو بحرب مؤكدة جراء هذه
الخطوة اليونان تتلقى الضربات من
المعاملات بالعملة المحلية مع
الدول الصديقة. هكذا قالها بوتين
مجلس الامن ليلغوا القرار بحق
الفيتو. هذا ونشرت مجلة نيوز ويك
احتفالات اسرائيلية بينما العراق
يعلن نجاح القرار الذي طرحه
بخصوص اسرائيل. فلماذا يقوم بعض
العرب بهذه الافعال? قديروف
فعلا. الرغبة بالحوار. قال
الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي ان اوكرانيا
والعالم بصواريخه. امريكا تضع
الفخ ليقع فيه المجنون ولكن
مع موسكو فهل يقبل بوتين
بالحوار؟ الناتو يجهز مركزا
لاغراض عسكرية فيما لن ترد على
تحضيرات السلطات الصينية لتدمير
محصنا لنقل السلاح الى اوكرانيا
فكيف سترد روسيا؟ هل موسكو
ان تعيدوا اسلحتكم ومرتزقتكم
وتطلبوا من الصفحة رسميا لم ندع
واضاف انا مهتم الان ببولندا. ما
الذي تحاول بولندا فعلا. اذا تم
الشمالية فما الذي ستفعله امريكا
الان؟ والصين تقولها للعلن لن
يهدد. قال الزعيم الشيشاني رمضان
قديروف ان عملية غزو انتهت
لكسر تحالفات الغرب وتجنب
عقوباتهم؟ زيلينسكي يرغب بالحديث
بوتين لتحالف جديد مع حلفاء
امريكا مصر والامارات هل هي خدعة
الرئيس الشيشاني؟ هل ينوي غزو
بولندا حقا؟ وهل هناك امر من
كلامية مستعرة بين امريكا والصين
وموسكو وبكين تنقذان مجنون كوريا
بوتين بذلك؟ البولنديون في قلق
هل سينفذ قديروف قوله؟ حرب
الحقيقي في ست ثوان. واستكمل
حديثه الموجه لوارسو. من الافضل
باي قمر صناعي يخدم امريكا في
سمائنا. فهل من رد امريكي خطة
استهدفت هذا الاسبوع موقع بارشين
العسكري شديد الحساسية خارج
معركة اوكرانيا انتهت حان وقت
بولندا. ما الذي يتحدث عنه
بين اقوى بلدان العالم.